Happy Easter weekend to all of you in
speaking of the resurrection of Christ
we now have a new trailer for a game
that we now know as Metal Gear Solid 5
the phantom pain so let's talk about
that's got a lot of requests to talk
about this to you like more than the
Wolverine trailer people like Wolverine
we don't give a [ __ ] talk about phantom
pain so as you guys know I'm a big Metal
Gear Solid fan and the phantom pain
trailer actually has a bit of a
backstory to it during PAX 2012 Hideo
Kojima released a trailer to Metal Gear
Solid Ground zeroes it was really cool
and it showed the Fox engine it shows
Big Boss doing this mission you're like
oh that's badass in a few months later
this random video this trailer for this
game called phantom pain came out people
were like solid it was a marketed as
Metal Gear Solid nor did anyone say
Hideo Kojima was attached to the project
it was his gameplay footage of phantom
pain here you go enjoy really how many
heroic military one-eyed mullets are
there in video games that had to be big
boss dude missing an army at like a
prosthetic hook arm but you're like
prosit big boss didn't lose an arm did
he and now it's been revealed that
phantom pain game yeah that's Metal Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain and to clarify
then you're like okay I guess Ground
Zero this is the same game and people
thought it was the same game and I guess
heyday Okajima said yeah it's all the
same thing but Konami is now telling us
now ground zeroes and phantom pain or
two separate games that's all we're
saying right now interesting intriguing
but holy [ __ ] it's like metal gears in
full force right now so the phantom pain
trailer starts out in big boss is in bad
shape he's back from a mission Kaz
Miller's next to him I like don't you
die on me dammit don't you tell on me
damn it
bp's dropping intubate now the Fox
engine does look really impressive you
got that JJ Abrams lens flares going on
you're like alright he's been brought on
the bridge at the enterprise and they're
doing CPR on big boss I don't know how
I'm not gonna enjoy this right now
but it took too long he's in a coma and
then he goes into a coma which is
interesting because the story's always
been he got wounded in battle he was
brought in he was in a coma that's when
the Lay's enfant or a project happened
the sun's a big boss were created
however it was always said that that
happened in 1972 but peace Walker took
place in 1974 that was always like its
are there are there timeline confliction
here and it does look like there are
which happens when you start adding lore
in between a story you've already
established however since this is
probably gonna be really bad as [ __ ] I'm
gonna be like all right I'll deal with
it that's what happens with timeline
confliction Zinn games when you can make
me still enjoy the game I'll be like
I'll forgive the timeline confliction so
when he goes into cardiac arrest and
doctors are like oh he's in a coma now
Cass Miller's like you're like who me
like the first person camera is Big Boss
not the main character in this game is
this other person the main character
they're not above that there was a time
they were like oh yeah Metal Gear Solid
dude and solace taken by Solid Snake we
mean writing and it looks like a lot of
the footage from this trailer is when
Big Boss wakes up from his coma
cuz he still has you know hospital pants
on he's got his prosthetic hook hands
and then [ __ ] is happening there's
really cool stuff that happens in this
trailer though I mean he shows him wipe
out this truck and it does the whole
like Inception slow-mo everything's
floating then you see weird [ __ ] like
you know a whale eat a helicopter and
you're like I don't know Metal Gear
Solid's always had that weird
supernatural element to it be it
psychological scientific or otherwise
whales eating helicopters are apparently
not absurdly strange however I saw this
one dudes like I a horse back and wait a
minute the dude has spurs and holy [ __ ]
is that revolver ocelot I don't know for
sure I'm pretty sure no one knows for
sure except the people who made the game
but I'm gonna say I'm pretty sure that's
revolver ocelot which automatically
makes me happy
you see outer heaven burning to the
ground where you're like how'd it happen
what happened and no it's not outer
Haven it's outer heaven outer Haven was
in Metal Gear Solid 4 outer heaven with
what big boss established and at the end
of this trailer this one doctor that
looks like Mike from Breaking Bad tells
Big Boss I'm afraid it's been so it is
possible that in the duration of big
bosses coma if that's when the sun's a
big boss were created they could be
around eight years old at this point we
don't know for sure though and that's
kind of the fun of talking about
trailers people are like why do you talk
about trailer because it's cool to
speculate dude that's what the
Internet's all about talking [ __ ]
speculating and porn the purpose of the
internet the weirdest part of the
trailer yeah weirder than the whale that
eats the helicopters at the very very
end of the trailer where it shows Big
Boss and he has a new unit Diamond Dogs
that's not the weird part the weird part
is that weird shrapnel horn in his head
what is that thing is that shrapnel is
that a piece of shrapnel that went into
his head you don't see it when they're
all doing CPR and I'm at the beginning
so it can't be what caused the coma is
it like Mass Effect you have the freedom
to be a dick and then you start growing
horns if you are the cool part is he has
that fake robotic hand at the end of
this trailer which looks to be the same
robotic hand that that one dude had and
peace walker that had the lighters and
the fingers just saying things are being
woven together in a really interesting
Hideo Kojima issue kind of way it being
a Metal Gear Solid game I am
automatically excited for it it's kind
of funny that Solid Snake has actually
been the star of a lot less games than
Big Boss has at this point if we don't
count Metal Gear 1 2 it looks like there
are some timeline alterations but if
they can make it cool I'm gonna be like
I don't care about continuity I guess I
do care about continuity but I am
willing to turn a blind eye and he has a
big piece of news on Metal Gear Solid 5
the phantom pain is the fact that David
Hayter is not going to be the voice of
big boss in this game it wasn't even
called back for it a lot of fans have a
lot to say about that I have my thoughts
on the subject but it's not so black and
white in my head or something like that
just I'd rather just do its own video on
it so I'll have that video to you on
Monday between now and then enjoy the
Cadbury cream eggs
all right so phantom pain officially
being Metal Gear Solid 5 phantom pain
have you seen the trailer what did you
think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]